[Music]
foreign
welcome back
so we have introduced this linear
differential equation with forcing in
fact this is a system of linear
differential equations with forcing
because a is a matrix and B is a matrix
and X is a vector containing all of the
states of my my system and this is a
really really important equation in
applied math because this is how we
model systems that we might want to
control or that are externally forced so
very very important to be able to solve
this and today I'm actually going to
derive this full-blown solution here in
terms of this convolution integral and
this e to the a t x naught and I'm going
to build it up very very simply in
little kind of bits and pieces I'm going
to introduce the Dirac Delta function
and kind of build up this convolution
integral here from scratch this is going
to be a pretty important interesting
lecture and it's actually going to
involve a little bit of math so this
might be a little bit more in the
challenging side but I hope to make it
extremely intuitive so anytime you see
this kind of system you know exactly
what all these terms mean you know how
to derive it and you know how to work
with it all right let's get started
so
the first thing we're going to do and in
general this is how we handle
um
this is how we handle differential
equations with forcing uh usually is
we're going to start by just looking at
the unforced or homogeneous equation x
dot equals ax
with some initial condition X naught
okay so kind of the first thing we're
going to do and I'll have to be a little
careful with my color management here
the first thing I'm going to do is kind
of case one
is going to involve
no control so U of T equals zero and an
initial condition uh
uh some initial condition X naught okay
this is kind of the trivial case I'm
going to start really really simple what
is the solution in this case where there
is no control obviously we know the
answer to that we know that the solution
this is the same as x dot equals ax with
no bu because U is zero and so the
solution is X of T equals e to the a
matrix
time times my initial condition X naught
okay this is the solution for the
unforced system and what I'm going to
sub problems of this big forced problem
and then add them up to get this uh this
full expression here okay so this is
kind of the simplest case with no
forcing kind of the homogeneous solution
this is often called the initial
condition response that's what I'm going
to call it this is the initial
condition
response
okay and that makes sense it's literally
if I have some initial condition this is
the response of the system to that
initial condition and what I'm going to
show now over over the next you know 5
10 15 minutes is that for a generic
control input U I'm going to draw maybe
a little picture
um at some point what I'm going to draw
is that for some generic control input U
for some U of T let's say this is U of T
what we're going to do is we're going to
think of this U of T as a sequence of
little kind of teeny tiny little
impulses a little kind of impulses these
little Delta use these little literally
like in calculus and Riemann you know
integrals we're going to think of these
as a bunch of little Delta U's and what
does a delta U do to my system so that's
what I'm going to look at at case two is
case two
is literally going to be
what if I have
um
no initial condition so X naught equals
zero so these are kind of the two
opposite cases here I had no control
forcing but I had an initial condition
here I'm going to have zero initial
conditions but I'm going to have a
control forcing and I'm going to say uh
and
U of T equals a little Delta function
I'll Define what I mean by a Delta
function but it's literally kind of like
one of these little a little discrete
Delta input to my system I'm going to
kick it a little bit it's a kick to the
system
uh and I'm gonna say my B Matrix let's
for now say B
is actually in the direction of uh of
this x naught Vector okay so B this this
B Matrix is just a single column which
is the column given by my uh my X naught
from up here in case one so this x
naught was a vector of initial
conditions and I'm going to pretend that
this B Matrix is that Vector of initial
conditions okay so bear with me this
will make sense in a minute okay
um and what I'm going to do is I'm going
to show you how this
um how this how this works okay so in
this case two
um this is going to be called an Impulse
response where because I'm giving an
impulsive input to my my system U
so
many of you might be thinking to
yourself what is the symbol delta T what
is this Delta function this like
discrete Delta input that Steve is
talking about so right now I'm going to
give you a little five or ten minute
vignette on what is the impulse response
what is this uh this Dirac Delta
function here
so
um
Delta of t
is known as the Dirac Delta function a
Dirac
Delta function
and it's it's like a generalized
function it's a weird function
because it has some strange properties
it's actually not like a well-defined
function it goes to Infinity at T equals
zero but it has an infinitesimal width
so that it's integral equals one so it's
literally defined so that the integral
from minus infinity to Infinity of Delta
of T DT
equals one so it's a shape that is
infinitesimally skinny and tall and has
area one so if you like you can think of
it as the limit of a little rectangle so
let's say this is T and let's say that
this is zero
and what you can do is you can take a
unit width rectangle
so you know it has height let's say it
starts with height one and width one and
I can start taking the limit as this
becomes skinnier and taller so that it
still has area one so I could take it
twice as tall and half as skinny or I
can take it you know four times as tall
and a quarter is skinny and I take the
limit kind of as this thing becomes
infinitesimally wide and infinitely tall
but so that its area is still equal to
one that's what this Delta function is
that's the direct Delta function so if I
integrate it you know if I integrate it
its area equals one but it is infinitely
thin and infinitely tall
and you can do that with rectangles you
can equally well Define your Delta
function as
gaussians you know this is my zero line
where I take the gaussian so that its
area equals one and I take the limit as
the variance becomes infinitesimally
small kind of infinitely small of that
gaussian and eventually it becomes a
smooth very peaky Delta function okay so
again this kind of progression as as you
take this this variance to zero this
gaussian this unit
uh unit area gaussian will approach this
Delta function that's how this Delta
function is derived and in fact you
don't even have to
have to from negative Infinity to
Infinity
uh the integral from minus Epsilon to
Epsilon
of Delta DT equals one
for any
positive Epsilon
even if Epsilon is
0.0001 the integral from minus 0.0001 to
0.0001 of my Delta function will equal 1
because this thing has unit area and
it's infinitesimally small so it's
entirely encompassed between minus
Epsilon and Epsilon
right so in all of its areas between
minus Epsilon and Epsilon for any
Epsilon you can name even if it's teeny
tiny okay so this is a weird construct
why am I inventing this crazy function
that has these properties it turns out
Dirac found this very useful in quantum
mechanics this is a necessary
function to do the kinds of calculations
that we need to do that I'm about to
show you
and so the Delta function
has this interesting property so
sometimes what I'm going to do is I'm
going to draw my Delta function as
uh let's say let's say in time often I
will draw my Delta function as an up
arrow that literally is the symbol I use
to mean this kind of limited Delta
function that has unit area but it's
infinitely skinny and tall
uh and let's say that this is U of T
equals you know some Delta of T and so
this is T equals zero
then the integral
of the integral
of U of T is going to be zero for all
time less than zero and immediately when
I cross over zero my area is going to
jump
to one
because this has and I think it's
yeah I think it jumps to one like that
because again this Delta function has
unit area so if I integrate past
uh the T where that Delta function is
defined my area instantly jumps to one
and stays there forever so that's how
this function works it's a weird
function but it's very very interesting
and useful and we're going to use it
here we're going to assume and
mathematically the way I think about
this in control systems is
I think of this as an Impulse an Impulse
to my system so if I have my you know
um Mass on a spring and I whack it with
a hammer I just like bang as fast as I
can so it's super super short in time
and a lot of energy there is a finite
amount of energy I'm putting into that
system a finite amount of area or energy
I'm putting into that system but I'm
doing it in an extremely short amount of
time so that whack that impulse
mathematically behaves a lot like a
Delta function and so that's why it's
super useful in control theory that's
called the impulse response often if you
have a system you would literally like
whack it you know with a little impulse
of energy watch how the system responds
and that would be a useful way to
characterize your system okay and that
would technically physically that would
correspond to you know maybe a rectangle
with a very very small width and a very
very tall height mathematically we're
going to approximate that as a Delta
function because it's going to be better
behaved
one more property I want to show you
about the Delta function I'll show you
this property in a minute that's Delta
functions so let's come back here so we
know how to solve this system If U of T
is zero how do we solve the system now
if I have no initial condition but I
have an impulsive input to U
and I'll just write this down that like
x dot equals a X plus b u that kind of
implies that X of T equals the integral
from wherever my initial condition was
let's say
um whatever like and whatever my initial
T naught to T
of everything in here I would just
integrate you know a X plus b u
H these are all functions of Tau D Tau
okay a is X is a function of Tau U is a
function of Tau in a role D Tau
initial condition so I'm actually going
to draw this response here of x
so this is you know X
of T let's say this is T you know
whatever my my zero time is
and I'm also going to show my
by you
of T and remember at U of T equals zero
I get this Delta function so I have a
Delta function right here at T equals
zero
and so if I think that my X of T equals
the integral of all of these Dynamics
right because literally I integrate in
time and it's the integral of this and
so on and so forth
if I start with zero initial conditions
if I start with zero initial conditions
I start at zero zero zero zero zero it
stays zero for all time this is zero
zero zero for any negative time this is
zero
and then immediately
equals zero
this U is a Delta function so the
integral right past that point jumps up
to one
so this jumps up to one at Time Zero
well technically jumps up to whatever B
is it jumps up to my value of B which is
X naught let's say x naught
and then for all future times this U of
T is equal to zero again but now it
looks like I have an initial condition
because my my X jumped up
to whatever B times Delta you know if I
integrate that it integrates up to B
times 1 which is B and I claim that I
started I made B to be this initial
condition so what I'm getting at is that
this looks a lot like an initial
condition response after the Delta so
before the Delta it's zero Dynamics so x
equals zero exactly when that impulsive
Delta happens
what's happening is that the integral
immediately jumps to one this integral
of U immediately jumps to one and so
this x immediately jumps to whatever
this B Vector is so X at time I would
literally say x at time 0 plus you know
an Epsilon an instant past times zero X
naught equals
whatever B is and I've chosen that to
equal x naught so I'm trying to convince
you that this impulse response looks
like an initial condition in this B
Direction so now I have an initial
condition in that b Direction and even
though U is zero for all future time now
you know X is non-zero and so now the
system evolves as if it was x dot equals
ax with this initial condition and let's
assume my Dynamics are stable and so now
this is what my future time response is
this is literally going to be e to the a
t times that X naught
and I didn't have to set b equal to X
naught I could have had some arbitrary B
and then the system would jump to X
naught plus equals B this would equal a
b and this would be a response e to the
a t times B okay maybe that would be an
easier way to think about it
so the long long way of saying
Delta function uh that has unit area but
infinitesimally short it's like if I hit
my system with a hammer and and just
immediately at Time Zero inject some
energy into the system some finite
energy into the system that's what
happens here if I have uh if I have U of
T equals a Delta I inject some finite
amount of energy into my system it looks
like starting at an initial condition X
naught equals B so at that time T it
looks like my system started at that
initial condition B
okay good
um
one more thing I'll show you is
um
let me see so an example of this so kind
of an example
would be okay let's try this again let's
say we have x dot equals a X plus b u
and I have X naught equals zero and I
have U now I'm going to say U equals
delta T minus 5.
okay we're going to look at what delta T
minus 5 is okay so instead of a Delta at
t 0 I'm going to have a Delta when T
equals five so all the way over here
okay so we're going to look at what that
looks like
so this is you
this is T again let's say 0 and 5. this
is where my Delta function happens I
probably shouldn't draw arrows here on
my left axis even though I usually do
okay this is my U axis
um
my u-axis
and I have a Delta function now at T
equals five you can convince yourself
that when T equals five this thing has a
Delta Delta at the Delta function is
infinite at zero and so this thing
occurs when T equals five that's when
this Delta function impulses to the
system so that's what U equals and so
what is our output response X
okay this is T and this is X and this is
0 and this is time five
so again just like we saw here
my initial condition is zero so kind of
for all time before 5
U is zero and U is zero and X is zero so
let's say x is zero so for all time
before 5
X is equal to zero and U is equal to
zero so X of T equals the integral of
zero is zero
but now at time five the integral of ax
plus b u immediately we gain some
impulse in energy because this is a
Delta function that has area one so
immediately at time five my system jumps
up
it jumps up at time five
to being a value which essentially that
value would be
um
X at time five plus Epsilon equals
the integral of B times that Delta
function is B
so you know X and b x equals B exactly
at time five so you know this is
whatever B is
and I'm drawing this as a scalar a
single X but you know if x has two
components then this would be you know
the first component there would be
another plot like this for the second
component and the first component of X
would equal the first component of b and
the second component of X would equal
the second component of b x is a vector
B is a vector and immediately at time
five x kind of jumps up to a value equal
to B because of this impulse in U so
um
you know X if I integrate this thing
then immediately when this thing gives
me an impulse and energy and integrates
to one then X at that time equals this B
Vector okay and then for all future
times U goes back to zero but now we
have this initial condition at x equals
B it's kind of like an initial condition
and so then the System Dynamics take
over and this is e to the A
now it's
T minus five because all of these
Dynamics start at T minus five times
that initial condition B okay so this is
literally what the what the trajectory
would look like for all future time so
for uh you can literally say x of T
equals equals zero for T less than five
and for T greater than or equal to 5 it
equals e to the A T minus five
B that's that's the solution of my
system
okay
fantastic okay so we now have the
building blocks to now start to think
about this General General system here
okay and I claim that now I can combine
these two I can take a system that has a
non-zero initial condition
and a Delta function at some time and I
can add those together and I will get
the superposition of those two so I'm
going to draw that as the last example
before I tackle this General case I'm
going to erase this part of the board so
just stay put
okay I'm going to do one more example
with Delta functions before I tackle
this General case and again remember in
the general case for an arbitrary
control input you know that does some
some function U of T I'm going to break
that down into a sequence of impulses so
I want to make you feel comfortable with
with these impulses
okay so case three
we're going to combine an initial
condition response and this impulse
response I should probably say this
here
is called an Impulse response
an Impulse response it's literally the
response of my system if I gave it a
Delta function input and when I say
Delta function you should think I hit my
system with a hammer really fast I give
a finite amount of energy in an
infinitesimally short amount of time
that's what an Impulse response is
mathematically we write it as this Delta
function this is an Impulse response so
here I'm going to combine an initial
condition response and an Impulse
response and show you what happens
so here now we're going to say U of T
equals a Delta function at T minus 5. so
we're going to keep our Delta function
at T minus 5 this impulse at Time 5
where B is
um
you know it equals B it's not I'm not
going to make it X naught this is a
little confusing it's just going to be
some Vector B that I choose B is B and
we have you know X at times 0 equals x
naught okay that's that's not the system
that we're going to
um to solve and I'm going to plot
everything as if B is a scalar number
and X naught is a scalar number but this
works for vectors X and and vectors B
just do what I'm doing for every single
component X1 X2 X3 X4 okay it not too
bad and so what I'm going to do is I'm
literally going to take the sum of this
impulse response and this initial the
simplest response in this initial
condition response and that's going to
be my solution
so let's just do this
and I'm going to try to give myself
enough room here so this is time
and let's start with my
um my initial condition response my
initial
condition
response is going to be that at time 0
at Time Zero my system X
is going to be it's going to go from 0
to X naught this is X naught
so it's going to go from zero
and it act at Time Zero it's going to be
X naught
and then the initial condition response
is just e to the a t times x naught and
I'm going to draw this for a stable a
matrix where it has negative real
eigenvalues just because it's going to
look easier
so
sorry it's so squeaky this is e to the a
t
X naught okay that's my initial
condition response
and I claim that the full solution for
this initial condition response and this
impulse response is just the sum of
these so it's Plus
my impulse response
which again what we're going to draw is
X versus T
time 0 let's say this is time five and
at time five that's where we're going to
have our Delta input at time five and so
at time five our system let's let's
assume we had a system without an
initial condition so we're solving the
initial condition system with zero
forcing
now I'm going to solve the system with
zero initial condition but with this
forcing and so for that system it is
zero remember
until time five and at time five I jump
up to a value B
and then my response afterwards is e to
the A
T minus five times B
and it's T minus five because
my Decay starts at time five whatever my
Dynamics e to the a t are they start at
at time five starting based at time five
so it's T minus five here and so I claim
that my my full system response my
actual uh and this is my impulse
response
my impulse response
so I claim that the total System
Dynamics here
are
now given by
the sum of these two responses which is
kind of nice and easy so I have time 0
and this is because linear superposition
holds because a is a matrix not a
non-linear function and B is a matrix so
linear superposition holds and I'll tell
you more about what this means but
essentially it means that if I if I
start at um
if I give it one control input U and
another control input and then I add
those two control inputs the output will
be the sum of the two independent
outputs so if I have control input 1 and
control input two and I have response
one in response to
then if I sum those control inputs the
response is the sum of those two
responses that's what it means to be a
linear system I'll have a whole lecture
talking about that maybe I've already
posted that and so here it means that I
can sum up my initial condition response
and my impulse and I get something that
now looks like
this so it's going to jump to you know X
naught
here
and it's going to be decaying
but it's not going to be completely at
zero by five and then it's going to jump
up to
you know this is going to be B plus
whatever you know e to the minus E to
the a t I'll write this in a minute and
then it's going to again slowly slowly
Decay so for here this is you know e to
the a t x naught
here this is e to the A
T minus five
B
plus whatever e to the a t was plus you
know e to the A
t
X naught and and you know starting at T
equals five there were still some
non-zero remainder here this wasn't all
the way decade to zero yet which is why
I drew this
um you know a little bit larger than
zero this little Delta here this is e to
the A5 X naught this is e to the A 5.
times x naught where T is evaluated at
5. and so this is the full solution here
is you know
um for times less than zero at zero for
times between zero and five it's e to
the a t x naught and for times greater
than five it's e to the a t x naught
plus this impulse response e to the A T
minus five times B
so I hope this makes sense that you can
break down your solution into an initial
condition response and the effect of
control and I've been keeping my control
simple these like very discrete Punk
date impulse responses because those are
the easiest ones to solve and to
integrate when I when I when I have an
Impulse in u
then for all times before that impulse
nothing happens and then immediately
after the impulse it's like I had an
initial condition at you know x equals B
and we know how to solve these initial
conditional responses so I'm trying to
convince you that my impulse response
looks a lot like a new Jump initial
Condition it's going to jump my initial
condition and then you know my Dynamics
take on after that
so now armed with this I'm ready to show
you how to do this for a generic U of T
and how to derive this function so I'm
going to erase some stuff and I'm going
to draw some stuff
just stay put
okay I realized I might need the entire
board for this one
so what we're going to do is now solve
for that output response
where my input U
H U of T this is T
where U of T can now be an arbitrary
function not just an impulse and what
I'm going to do is I'm going to break
this down into a bunch of little teeny
tiny impulses so I'm going to um
you know I'm going to basically say I
have
um
you know Time Zero time one time two
times three dot dot dot dot all these
kind of little times separated by delta
T okay so you know t
TK plus 1 minus TK is delta T these are
a little like fixed delta T time steps
and I'm going to approximate the area
under this curve as a little Delta
function with that area
and so my Riemann sum so I'm literally
going to say that
um
I'll draw I'm going to draw the same
picture over here because I'm going to
use this one to draw like the sum
summation and here I'm going to draw a
kind of what I mean by this Delta
function
so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to approximate
the area in each of these little bunches
each of these little Riemann
you know area pieces each of these
little rectangles what I'm going to do
is I'm going to approximate that as a
train
of impulses as a little train of
impulses so this is an Impulse this is
going to be a slightly bigger impulse I
mean you can see kind of that this
should match the shape of you because
these impulses are related to the area
under each of these curves and so this
impulse
is going to be
um let's take the simples here
let's call this um you know at T
at some t
this is you
of T is approximately equal to a Delta
function at T
times whatever that little
um
infinitesimal area is there which I'm
going to claim is U of
T times a little delta T okay so
whatever whatever the um
let me let me just write this as this
delta T So this
the amount of Delta function at this
point that I need to capture that area
is
okay this little area here
it is the height U of T
times the width delta T that area needs
to be in that Delta function this Delta
function has to have an area equal to
that U of T that height times that delta
T okay
and so here's where it gets kind of cool
is we can consider uh this infinitesimal
series of teeny we can take the limit as
delta T goes to zero so now this area is
infinitesimal and this is a continuous
train of Delta functions I hope that
makes sense so we're going to take the
limit
as delta T goes to zero this becomes
an infinite train
infinite train
of infinitesimal Delta functions
infinitesimal
Delta functions
which is another way to say at every
instant in time each of these U of T's
each of these U of TS at every point in
time is acting like a little
infinitesimal Delta function it's
kicking my system this hard and then a
little harder and a little harder a
little softer a little softer a little
harder and like this is these are each
little infinitesimal Delta functions
with infinitesim as I take delta T goes
to zero these have infinitely small
areas but they you know they add up over
time because this is a continuous
variable now so that's what I'm going to
draw here is now the solution X of T is
going to equal
the sum
of whatever my initial condition
response is so I I always am going to
have some uh let's say you know
X naught
and at time 0 I'm going to have my
initial condition response okay so this
is my initial condition
let's say this is Time Zero
okay so I have my initial condition
response and then I'm going to have the
effect of all of these infinite trains
of Delta functions so Plus
whatever my control input U is the Delta
function
um
there will be a little Delta function
here which is
at Time Zero I'm trying hard to get this
actually right for you uh so you know
the first one is at time zero and that
would be u0 delta T
times this Delta function
so this is U zero
DT
uh in the B Direction so u0 at times
delta T is how much area is in that
Delta function
and so at Time Zero I go that much in
the B Direction it's like an initial
condition a teeny little jump in my
initial condition equal to B times U of
0 delta T okay and I'm going to draw it
a little bigger than it actually is
but of course it's infinitesimal this
will be an infinitesimal height because
this is a DT okay so there's that at
time zero and then at time you know
whatever the next little instant in time
I'm going to try to draw this discreetly
um you know now at time whatever delta T
I have another little jump
which is you know you at that time T DT
times B that's going to be a little tiny
infinitesimal impulse response
Plus
uh you know and then it's going to be
shifted plus dot dot dot dot and so I'm
going to get a bunch of these shifted
trains of impulse responses where each
one of these impulse responses is going
to have magnitude you at that instant in
time times DT that's going to be the the
area you know of U of T this is how much
is in each of these little impulses that
are continuous each of these little
impulses is adding a little bit to my
initial condition at time now and the
next DT and the next DT and the next DT
and the next DT I get all these impulse
responses and if I add all of those up
and let's see if I how good I am uh my
art classes have paid off I've never
taken any art classes ever uh what I get
is something that you know at Time Zero
of course I start off at X naught
and now all of these are adding up
continuously to give me something you
know that's gonna so so this is going to
be decaying but I'm adding an Impulse in
you and so I keep adding these things
that are then decaying and I'll get some
you know response and then whenever my
control stops eventually things will
just Decay to zero okay according to e
to the a t
so that's the picture is that we have
this sum of trains of impulses
um because of this U of T but now we're
actually ready to write this
mathematically so essentially this is
um and I haven't actually done this
before I'm a little worried or I haven't
done this in a while that I'm going to
get something like X of t
equals
and each of these things is an e to the
A
let's say that this is based at not
delta T but you know this is sometime
Tau okay this is some time Tau
so this is going to be e to this is
starting at time Tau so it's e to the A
T minus Tau
times whatever that little initial
condition bump was which is B
U at that Tau U at that Tau
uh detail okay so with that little Tau
at every little single towel I have an
Impulse response with area U at that Tau
whatever you was at that Tau that's the
times delta T is the area of that
impulse so it jumps me to a place b u
Tau D Tau and then for all future times
the system decays according to the the
Dynamics e to the a t but again centered
at T equals Tau so e to the A T minus
Tau B U of Tau D Tau and I'm adding up
all of these I'm integrating from zero
to Infinity over D Tau I'm adding up you
know when tau is zero and tau is delta T
and tau is two delta T and three delta T
the shifting average
so it equals my initial condition
response e to the a t x naught
plus this integral from 0 to T
whatever you know time I want to measure
this thing at some time x of T this is
integrating up until t
all of these little impulse responses e
to the A T minus Tau
times B
times U of Tau D Tau and so this is the
area of my impulse response this is the
little you know jump in initial
conditions because of that impulse
response and this is the decay of that
because of the Dynamics and I add all of
those up uh shifting in time so this is
the the full answer
and this is a convolution integral
convolution this is a very convoluted
argument
um convolution integral
I mean I think they're probably if you
slowed down or if you rewound or if you
paused and convinced yourself I think
this does make sense but this does feel
a little convoluted this was a long
lecture this convolution integral and
the way we say it is we would say okay
let's define h
of t
equals e to the a t
be
then this integral here is literally
defined as the convolution of H
with u that's like this is literally the
definition of the convolution of e to
the a t b with another function U of T
convolution of H with u where H and
again H is called I believe this is
called uh
uh this is called the impulse response
this is the impulse response
like literally if I put in a Delta
function to U this would be the response
and so what we have now we can
understand this kind of pretty simply
this response here is just the
convolution or the continuous shifting
integral or shifting sum of all of these
teeny tiny little impulse responses all
of these teeny tiny little impulse
responses h
with the magnitude of U delta T so
whatever U is at this time times delta T
that's how much impulse response I get
and then at the next instance whatever U
is at that instant times delta T that's
how much impulse response I add there
and I keep adding these little teeny
tiny little infinitesimal Delta function
impulse responses in this kind of time
shifting way and if I add all of those
up I get my true system response X of t
okay so that was a lot but I hope this
was all you know all the steps were
simple and made sense building on this
Delta function up until this full
convolution integral
all right thank you
[Music]